すべての現象は縁起により生じるものです
それは仏教の話 しかし
それを発見したのはお釈迦様です
で 心の中にWhyが存在することが
その人が縁起を探していることです
本当はどうったことない
我々の頭の中にWhyがいるんですよ
幽霊みたいに住み着いて
なかなか除霊したっても逃げていかないし
あれは除霊するもんじゃないんです
あれがないともうバカに無知に無明になっちゃうんです
だから頭の中でWhyというなぜということをずっと私たちはいじめていじめてもいるんだけど
それによって人がもう発展して発展して発展していくんです
それで誰も気づいてないんだけど
我々は縁起を探しているんです
人類が しかし ブッダの縁起法則は
これはもう邪教の教えで
神を冒涜する教えで みんな悪魔のたからいで地獄に直行でいくんだよとよく言われているんです
と もう自分の国なら キリスト教もじりじり元気で頑張っているし
イスラム教も頑張っているし
もう仏教の人々はみんなもう悪魔のたからいですね
自分たちはもう神のもうかわいいフェイバリットの存在で
そんなこと言いつつも
宗教信仰をしているバカどもたちも
無宗教のアホの人々も
誰でも縁起を探しているでしょうに
なんで縁起を語っている人を敵に回すんですかね
だからお釈迦様 堂々とみんなバカやと
です バカでしょ 自分が縁起を探しているのに
縁起を探している人はあんたバカでしょと言うと
バカはそちらでしょうに
だから人類ならWhyがあるんです
だから人類なら縁起を探しているんです
ですから 仏教は君を探しているものを見つけてあげる
あげますと言っているんだから
だから仏教を学ぶ人は随分安らぎと充実感と味
味わいます 心の安穏と曖昧が消えちゃうんです
しかし 俗世間でこの変な思考の持っている人々とはレベルが違うんです
だから仏教の人々は異論いくらあったってもへっちゃらなんです
むちゃくちゃ寛容なんです
ああそう 君そう思ってるの？それで終わっちゃうんです
殺してやるとは思わないんです
仏教のお母さんとお父さんには
子供がとんでもない もう仏教も何でも大嫌いの子どもが生まれたっても
ああ あの子は好きじゃないんだからねということで
何のこともない 放っておくんです
しかし 悪いことはさせません
君の意見はどうでも勝手でいいんだけど
こういうこういうことはするなよと
そこでものの見事に勧誘があっても
人にはいい加減で もうわがまま好き勝手に生きていて
世界に迷惑をかけることもさせない
はい それで仏教がそこの時点から割り込みます
仏教はもうはっきりとWhyの宗教なんです
それ今日申し上げてみたいけど What
Why 次にまた  Then ということが
それなら答えは何ですかと
次にまた How が入ります
4つのステップで解かれていますね
この四聖諦 だからこれ聖なる真理なんです
無知 観察能力に欠けていて
無知でね さらに欲 怠け
怒りなどの感情に支配されているので Why
に適当な答えを妄想して納得するんです
そこで人間が縁起を見つけるのではなくて
もうもう簡単になんとかWhyに答え出しちゃうんですね
これは答え出すと まず無知ですね
自分が原因探ってるんだっていうことには気づいてないんです
何か法則を見つけ探してるんだということに気づいてないんです
ただ 私は探しているんだよ
何を探しても それよくわからないんだよという人生なんです
それっておかしいでしょ？私は探してます
何を？それよくわかりません
あなたと喋る暇がありません
忙しい なんで私は探してます
だから余裕はありません
それはわかりません だからあなた何探ってるの？それわかりませんよ
そんな人生はなり方ないでしょ
しかし 仏教からそれを言わない限り
みんな気づかないんです
どんな人でも何か探し求めているんです
それが何かとわかってないんです
ですから そこは無明というんです
だからエゴでは I am エクスプローリング What
are you エクスプローリング？I don't というか
スターなんです そういうわけで疲れるんだから
怒りで感情で主観でこうではないかと
もうすぐ 結論を出しちゃうんですね
旦那さんがもう結婚記念日は忘れちゃって
その日夜も 12時まで家に帰る帰らなかったと
で これ 結婚記念日を忘れたわけじゃなくて
忘れることは当然ですけど
男っていうのは早く忘れたいんだから
それは で  仕事の関係でいろいろあって
もうとつとく 突然もう会社で何かもう何か状況が変わった
変わることもあったりしてね
それで 奥さんが別世界で夫は遅い
なぜ？私の今日 結婚記念日です
私はそれはお祝いしてほしいと
ああ この人はこれで逃げているんだ
サボっているんだということは
実はね 本当にどこかで女作ってるでしょ
はい 答え見つけた あれ
不倫というの？不倫でしたっけ？不倫しているんだと
旦那がくったくた疲れて家に来ると
これ大変ですね もう物はぶん投げるわ
怒るわ 怒鳴られるわ 家から外へ出すわ
で 男はなぜ？まだ男になぜが出てくるでしょ
で 男もそれなりに この女は結婚してる時でもあまりにも凶暴でヒステリーでイカれているんだから
今日はかなり発作を起こしているって
そちらもうちのうちの人はまあかなりイカれている人で
よく気をつけてなくちゃいけないんだと
発作を起こしている時は
まあ冬は真冬であっても
外へ出しちゃったらそのままいるしかないんだとかね
そこは別な世界で そういうふうにどちらでも正解見つかってないでしょ
しかし いくら言っても
これはお互い様 もう理解してもらうことは不可能なんですね
いくら言っても やがて亡くしたっても
あの問題解決してないんです
だから人間のこの why の答えは当てにならない
もうどこかで感情が絡んでるんです
だから妄想なんですね
ほとんどの知識は 知識の中でものすごい大量に妄想が入っているんです
ですから 縁起以外何もないのに
人はそれを発見しないんです
で 起きてる出来事を見ると
こうだからこうなる こうだからこうなるっていうことは
あら またこれ一つのなんか縁起なんでしょうと
それが発見しないんですね
例えば奥さんにプレゼントをあげる
奥さんが喜んじゃうと
それで終わり 研究は まあだったらうちの人は何かプレゼントもらったらすぐ気分がいいんだよと決めても良いんだけど
そうじゃなくて まあ女っていうのはね
まあ何かプレゼントあげちゃえばね
まあ喜んでくれますよと
これで普遍的なことにしているんですね
プレゼント開けてひどい目に遭うケースもありますけど
喜んでくれるどころじゃなくて
相手に借金までさせて金も取りたい放題取る人もいるし
だからもうちょっと科学的に調べた方がいいんです
まあ一人の被験者でもいいんだけど
ある日はケーキを持ってプレゼントを持ってきたよとかね
はい プレゼントをもらって喜んだかとかね
それでありがとうという程度でしょうね
それで今日はありがとうだけ言って
喜びの結果はこれで 次の日はじゃあ
何でしたっけ？じゃあ何かカバン持っていく
結構お金もかかったしね
あ びっくり カバン あ 見て
やっぱりこの色 私あんまり好きじゃないねとか
その人はデータ取らなくちゃいんです
高価なものをあげました
カバン しかし 好みではないと言ったことは
喜びたいが喜べないという結果ですと
それで次の日はある ある日
もうある花束を持っていくと
ああ 嬉しいわとかね 喜んじゃって
あ 花をあげた プレゼントとして素直に喜んでくれたと
はい やっぱりこの人は女ではなくてね
この人は花をもらうと喜ぶ
いて じゃあ花の世界で頑張るぞと
この男はそれで決めちゃって
次は じゃあ高い花をあげたらもっと喜ぶでしょうと
で このバラの高いバラの花のなんか青いバラの花ありますね
見たことないんですけど
あるみたいです  1本何千円もかかるって
じゃああれ  3本ぐらい
それで持っていったらむちゃ喜ぶはずでしょ
その人 あれあれ 珍しい
珍しいね これは でも私はあまりバラっていうのはあんまり好きじゃないねとか
本人が珍しいバラであることを知ってるんだけど
バラは嫌いんですね だから前の決まり
この人は花をもらうとむちゃ喜びますよということをまた訂正しなくちゃいけないんで
しかし バラだけはあげるなよと
はい それでじゃあ決めましょう
百合の花が大好きやと
そうするともう百合の花をいくら持って行ったって
まあよかった よかった
楽しい 楽しい 嬉しいとかね
なると それで何回も何回ってみると
まあこの嬉しいのレベルが下がったり上がったり下がったり上がったり
それまたなんでやと また調べなくちゃいけないでしょ
だから本人が物体として好きなものをあげているんだけど
もう嬉しさっていうのはバラバラですねと
それまた調べると なんであんた今日そんなに喜ばないの？だってあんた昨日も同じ花持ってきたよ
それ全部あちこち もうあれまだまだ元気だからね
あれ捨てたくないんだよと
私はもったいないんだから
また今日持ってきちゃう
あれ捨てちゃって また別に来る
あんなもったいないことしたくないんだと
それでまたもう一つ原因を見つけたでしょ
そういうことで この大変ですよ
因果法則は そう簡単に結論に達することはできないんです
今の例でわかるでしょ
だからお釈迦様ならそこを決めるんです
映画もらうとこの人に喜びというものは生じると
それ正しくであれば 映画がないとこの人にが生じないでしょうと
そういう方程式で考えちゃうんですね
はい 今の例を説明すると
この人は喜ぶが 確実にプレゼントだから喜んだわけじゃないんです
プレゼントの中にもいろいろいろいろ原因がありまして
この程度の原因があると喜びますけど
それまた喜ぶ結果もむちゃくちゃやと
喜びにも自分のプレゼントだけではなくて
この人の気持ちのまた条件があるんだと
その人の理解 能力 世界観
価値観 その時の気分 疲れているか
休んでいるか そういう状況によっても喜びのレベルが変わるんだから
それでじゃあシンプルにしましょう
プレゼントという原因がある
喜びが生まれたという結果があるでしょ
よくよく見ると その結果もまた別な原因が割り込んできて左右するんですね
ですから プレゼントをもらうと人は喜ぶということは
普遍的な真理にはなりませんね
なのに仏教では得ることを
人は喜びと言ってます
はい それに異論がある？何か得る
もらう いただく 自分のものになる
それでは人が喜ばない？まあ
その程度で言えば なんとなく本当のことのように聞える
聞こえるでしょ だからそうやってできるだけこのプリンシプル
この方式っていうか 方程式というか
フォーミュラを見つからなくちゃいけないんです
数学みたいに 仏教はそれをやってるんだからね
もうもう大変難しいんです
では 私は今言ったのは
皆様をからかうために言ったんです
得ることで喜びますよと言ったら
まあそれならやっぱりそうでしょうと思うでしょ
では 病気がいたらどうする？喜ばないでしょ
だったらだから得ることで喜ぶとか成り立ちませんね
もっと訂正しなくといけないんです
期待するものを得ると喜ぶんです
それだったらどう？人は期待
希望するものを得ると喜びます
期待しそうもないものを得るとは
喜ぶんじゃなくて逆になるんです
はい そういうことで何か何がわかるのかというと
何でも原因があって起こるんですね
その程度はわかりますね
原因がないと何も起こらないんです
この原因は何かというと
私たちはもう手上げありすぎ
把握できないほど絡み合って絡み合って絡み合ってあるんです
だからタイトル縁起のネットワークなんです
だから簡単に結論だけは出してはいけません
一神教は極限に無知な人々が考え出した why の答えです
しかし この答えは縁起を否定するんです
それで人間はもうなんで
なんで なんで全部頭ぐちゃぐちゃになるんです
例えば女性とプレゼントのケースを見ても
もういや 女ってわからないもんやとかね
理解しようと男はプレゼントをあげてずーっと研究したんだけど
どうもうまくいかないんですね
それで決める やっぱりこの人がその日その日で希望するものをもらっちゃえば喜ぶでしょうと
だから聞いちゃえば簡単やん
言って じゃあもう今度ね
ちゃんと君にプレゼントあげたいんですけど
何が欲しい？何が欲しいと
じゃあこれこれをと言う
で 欲しい人はそれを買ってあげたりして喜んじゃう
言ったことはくれたと
はい あ これでよかった
もう正解見つけた 聞けばいいと
はい それでいいと思う
それでうまくいくと思う
で 次の日もまた今度のプレゼントに何が欲しいとかね
そうすると 2回目も言うかもしれません
それでその人は確実に知ってます
自分言ったことは買ってくるだろうと
もう最初から知ってるんだからね
リボンがあって あれでこれでもう包装して
はい どうぞとくれたっても
中身知ってるんだからね
もう意味がないでしょ
本人はその品物を店で見たことがあるんだから
それ欲しいと言ったでしょうに
だからあの箱を開けても
あ なんだこれって喜びないんですね
だから聞いてみたっても
そんな結果になる それでこれ
どんどん時間経って この男っていうのは本当にイメージレーションも何もない
不満もない もうなんだこのゾンビは？とかね
自分で要求してもらったって
これプレゼントにならないでしょうにと
嫌なやつやと 気持ちぐらいわかってほしいと
また逆になっちゃうんですね
どんどんどんどん だからその人はせっかく長い年月かけて研究していたのに
やっと何か結論に達したのに
聞けばいいかと それもまた時間が経つと逆効果になってしまう
はい そういう例でよく覚えてください
この因果法則っていうのは結構ややこしいもんなんですよ
だからそれは最終的に見つけたならば
どれほど智慧のある人かと
仏教は最終的にそれを見つかっているんです
見つかっただけではなくて
これ以上はないんだと
もし誰かこれは違うと言うならば
これありえないんだと
違うと思うならば言ってみろよという調子でお釈迦様はこの最終結論を教えられています
それで人間っていうのはもういいや
うるさいんだということで
もう考えたくないという人々が一番頭の悪い人々は
まあこれでかこれやるしね
もう例えば今度はみかん
みかんの出来がすごく悪いんだとか
なんで悪いんだ もう雨がもう降らなかったんだからとかね
まあ去年のみかんの出来がもう全くダメでしたと
なぜかというと もう雨がガーガーと降りすぎちゃって
日が当たらなかったと
適当に全部落ちてしまったと
もっと前の日はもう台風が来ちゃったと
そのぐらいの原因は知っている
その人はなんで 3年続けて私のみかんはダメになったんですかと
私はもう借金やと はい
それに答えがある なんで 3年続けて
ちょうどもう今週はみかん取れるぞと思ったら
もうまた台風が来るとかね
そうでしょうに それでその人は
ああ なんか新宿に行って占ってでももらおうかなとかね
成田山に行って祈祷でもしてもらおうかなとかね
泉水供養でもしなきゃあかんかなとか思っちゃうでしょ
あれっていうのは相当無知怠けなんです
だって その結論に達するためには
何の証拠も理由もないでしょ
もう考えられないんですね
考える能力がないんです
だから適当に答え見つかるんです
泉水供養しちゃえばいいやとかね
墓参りで行っちゃえばいいやとかね
そういえば俺は 5年間も墓参りに行ってないんだ
こうかもしれませんと
あるいは新宿や銀座やどこか行ってね
高いお金払って占い占ってもらうとか
なんとかことになっちゃうんですね
それでなんで人間が我々いるんでしょうかとか
なんで我々にはもうまあ
時には食べ物があって
時には食べ物はない 子供
生まれたんだけど ほとんど死んじゃったとかね
子供欲しいんだけど生まれてこないんだとかね
あれやこれやなんでばっかしなんですね
それである人々は雨が降らないのは雨が降らしてくれる神が腹立っているでしょう
で 雨が降らなかったら
その雨の神様に拝み もう一応作物雨が降るんだけど
なかなかもう虫に食われちゃって
もうそれほど豊作にならない
あ これは土の神様がね
まあ機嫌が悪い 土の神様に礼をしなかったからと
それで決める ああ 納得
吾輩は納得 だから田んぼを畑作る前に
ちょっとお供え物を用意しておいて
明かりもつけて もう何か線香も立てて
土の神様 私たちの今年もよろしくお願いしますと
それから畑 田んぼを作ったりして
それで山の場合は山の神様が出てきて
それ漁師たちはもう川の神様は海の神様を作ったりして
そうなってくると人間に問題があったら
それの神様が現れるでしょ
で 子供は授かってくれないというのは
また変な神秘宗教の言葉ですけど
子供は産めない 産めないではなくて
もう妊娠しない 科学的にオナコチャなんだからね
じゃあ女性がいる でも子供が欲しいんですね
欲しいんだけど なかなかこれが妊娠しないんですね
ちょこちょこと妊娠したような気配するんですけど
もう1ヶ月とかいなり
それずっと出てっちゃうとかね
あら これには神様が必要ですね
ですから 子宝に恵まれてくれる
子供を授けてくれる神様が作るんですね
それで子供はいるんだけど
そっちを病気になると
子供は病気にさせる悪霊がいて
子供を守ってくれる もうまた子守りの神様も作るんですね
仕事を別で それでもいくらでも作れますよ
病気は 138種類があるんだったら
人間にかかる それぞれの病気に神一人一人一人作ることはできます
だから人間の問題の数に合わせた悪霊か神霊か作ることはとても簡単に数学的にできるでしょ
どうなるんですか？結果は
八百年の神様が生まれてくるんです
八百って何？何？な 数字は何でしたっけね
えっ  800 うん あのインドではもう億単位で神々がいるんです
数えています 全部神々の数
ちょっと今忘れちゃったんですけどね
これは歴史で現れた この
何と言うんですか このポリテイションと英語では言うんですね
たくさん神々を拝むと
神々はもうもう 8万作るのはいいんだけど
もうできる 皆様に 8万4000の神々にお供えすること
できるわけないでしょう
こんな暇があるわけでもないでしょう
ですから やっぱり神の世界でも政府とか作らないとね
神の大臣とか 神の王様とか
作ってもらわないと インド文化では神大臣格があるんですね
だから大臣に訴えるか
王様に訴えるかということになっちゃうんですね
これは面倒くさいんだから
もういいや もう何も考えません
神が1匹しかないんだと
この中東と西洋の世界で考えるという
だから世の中で一番無知な
極限に無知な人が思う
だからとにかく原因をちゃんと調べなきゃ
無知 もうもう話にならない
好き勝手な答えを出すんじゃないんです
私の話はよくわからないのは今日日曜日だからとかね
そんな好き勝手なことを言ってはならない
それでは無知に決まってるでしょ
だからこの絶対的神を作った人々は
もうあえて病的な無知なんです
それで絶対的神を作ったら
その神は全知全能でなければいけません
そこからは論理的なんです
一切を創造して維持管理する人
神であるならば 絶対的な
全知全能でなければいけません
我々は生きていきたいし
生きることで喜びもらいたいんだから
神様はいいやつでなければいけません
悪魔では困ります それは期待してない
だから神は善 善でもなければいけません
そこまで論理的 そこから世の中を見ると
いいことばかりではなくて
悪いことばかりで どのいいことっていうのはそう起こらないんですね
また新たな現象にぶつかったんです
それで今の答えとまた対立するんですね
あら 神ならそんなことするはずがない
ですから 悪魔作りましょうと
で 悪魔を作るんです 悪魔はもう神の反逆者で
神のライバルで また問題
あ 神にライバルなんて全知全能でならないでしょう
神にライバルがいると
神はそいつは潰しちゃえばいいんだからね
でも潰してくれないんですね
ということは おそらく神が時期を待ってるかもしれませんね
全部潰すために それがユダヤ教とかキリスト教なんです
時期が来るんです 神が降りてくる
やばい 神を信仰してない連中はみんな潰すんです
で 地獄に落とす だからそれっていうのは
決して理性のある人を考えるものじゃないんです
一旦間違った答えを出したら
それからいくらか論理組み立てますけど
矛盾だらけになるんです
それでそういう人々が因果法則を否定するんです
すべて神が決める で 特にイスラム教は
この世界はもう神が作った世界であって
世界のことはもう神の勝手で動くんであって
人間あれこれやってやってはいけませんと
どれほど厳しいかで 神が作ったものの模型さえも作ってはいけませんよ
だから芸術活動はもうとんでもない神の冒涜なんです
でもやっちゃいますね
この連中が もうなんでやってるかわかりませんだけど
食って寝ればいいんです
芸術活動はダメですけどね
だから特に人間を描いてはいけないというね
すごい厳しいんですね
人間描くっていうことは
人間を作ったのは神だから
もう神を冒涜することになりますね
だから人間の像を作ったり
絵を描いたりといけない
あるどこかで これでイギリス人のかアメリカ人の女の人がボランティアに行って
子供たちに教育ないんだから
イスラム国ではね 教育なんかしてあげて
イギリスの文化なんです
それで本当にできるのは絵を描くことなんですね
それでもうすごいもう反対されちゃって
これはもうコーランの教えに逆らいますよと言って
話し合って話し合って話し合って
じゃあ 人間は断然的に禁止ですから
子供たちは動物程度ならまあいいんだと
でやって また絵を描く場合はまた何か決める
使う決まり 決まりを作ってもらって
随分厳しい状況で子供たちにも絵を描く方法を教えたりしているんだという話を聞いたことはあります
だからそこもまた矛盾なんですね
何も神が作った世界で模型を作ってはならんと言ったら
家も作れないでしょうに
だから一つは論理を作ると
またどこかで矛盾が見えてくるんですね
だから彼らが断言に因果法則には反対なんです
断然的に反対 自分で自分の運命を決めるということはもう恐ろしい
それでと言っても その人々も縁起を探ったんです
で あまり考えたくなかったんだから
生きる状況はあまりにも苦しくて
考えたくなかったんですね
それで神秘的な答えに納得しただけなんですけど
それで彼らが因果法則を否定するんですね
しかし 我々には因果法則以外は何も語れません
キリスト教も頑張っちゃいますね
何か理論をつけてやるよと
イスラム教も何か理論をつけよう
だって豚肉食ってはいけないとありますでしょ
理由が出てこない なんでやと
だから頑張るんです こういうわけで
こういうわけで食べちゃいけないとかね
もうおかしりに書いてしまったんだけどね
当時の人々は豚が怖かったと
なんかすごい怖かったし
なんか聖なる動物やと思ってたみたいですね
昔々 ユダヤ人の間では
踊りちゃうんだそうです
だからこうなかれとも書いちゃ書いてしまったと
しかし 時代が変わっていくと
もう訳を言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
で 苦労して訳を書こうとするんです
貝魚介類を食べてはいけないって
なんでやと で そういうふうなことになっちゃいますね
で 仏教でもね 托鉢にでも
馬の肉 ゾウの肉とか もう虎の肉などなど
ヘビの肉とかね 人は欲したら断ってくださいと
という食べてはいけない肉のセットがあるんです
お釈迦様 答え簡単 なんでやと
人間がそれ嫌い 嫌いだから
わかりやすいでしょ なんだ
そこまでこうなのかと
気持ち悪いでしょうと普通思っちゃいますよと
だからその程度で その程度ならしっかりした論理なんです
わしがそう決めたんだからすみやって
それはないんです もう時間でしょうかね
今日 佐藤さん  うん まあそろそろですね
もう3分の4分の１も進んでないんです
次 あの 2番目 ちょこっとそれで終わりにしましょう How
ということ あの経験する現象が好ましい
好まない 良くない 受け入れたくない場合は
その状況から抜け出すためにHowという宿題が心に入るんです
で How Why の次にHowが出てくるんです
人が病気になっちゃうでしょ
なぜということはまず出てくる
それで終わらないんです
病気治しちゃいたい 治したいんですね
それでHowという問題が出てくるんですね How
も因果法則なんです という同じことですね
物事は縁起だからこそ
人はHowに適切な答えを見つけられます
そこで物事は縁起だからHowは見つかるんですよ
例えば この人は病気になっちゃった
なぜ？いきなりなぜに飛ぶんですけど
仏教はいきなりなぜに飛ばないんです
1この人は病気である
それは何なのかと What
ということに挑戦する
それを知り尽くしちゃうんです
それからなぜ しかし病気は嫌なんですね
治したいんですね それでHow
ちゃんと原因を見つけたらもうできます
だから縁起だから このHowは成り立ちます
今頃はもう太陽はもうなかなか上がってこない
だからもうこちらに入ってくる熱量が少ない
で これで超寒い 当たり前ですね
だからといってそれは受け入れたくないんですね
当たり前ですけど それで我々はHowということで
もう外はどうでもいいんだけど
住んでるところだけでも暖かくしたいということで
いろんなHowを見つけるんです
だから外はもう0度以下かもしれませんよ
家の中はものすごく暖かく
もうやってますよ 縁起だからそれできてるんです
だから世の中は縁起なんです
しかし この場合も誰も最終的答えを見出せてないんです
しかし Howの場合も
最終的な答えは人間が見つからないんですね
まあ風邪引いたらこれHowでなんとか治せますけど
それでその項目が終わっちゃうんです
肺炎になったら それはまた別病気で別なHowが必要になっちゃうんです
そのように問題あるたびに様々なHowが欲しいんだけど
それ見つからないんだから適当に
例えばウイルス感染で病気になったらまだ答え見つかってないんですね
だからまあもうなんとかなんとか
もう他のあの合併症っていろいろ出てこないようにちょっと抑えていくだけで
もう体が自分で治すまで待つという
それも一つのHowの答えなんですね
体が抗体作ろうんだそうと
それからいいワクチンを作りましょうというシステムもありますね
そんな世界なんですね
それでWhyとHowまとめたら因果法則なんですね
縁起はなぜとどうすればという 2つの側面があります Why
神に逆らったから人は苦しんで生きる
死ぬことになる How
神を信じる 懺悔をするなどなど
宗教によって答えがたくさんありますね
だから この生きることのWhy and Howというね
ことは宗教ではそうなってますね
でもそれは正しい答えじゃない
いい加減な答えなんですね
科学などの知識世界もWhyとHowという 2つの側面を持つ縁起によって成り立ってますね
すべての科学 すべての知識は縁起によって成り立っているんです Why
とHow 科学は明らかにWhyとHowでやってます
しかし 世界は因果法則を語らないんです
なのに科学者さえ因果法則というものを語らないんですね
語ったのはお釈迦様だけです
世界の因果論 時間というラインの上で因果を考えているんですね
これカットしましょうか
で これここからめっちゃ難しくなるんです
あの 一応我々因果法則で
このなんで答えが見つからないのかというと
この時間 時間のラインを設定してYを探すんですね
だから当然原因は過去で
結果が現在になるんですね
時間のラインで これだけじゃないんで
例えば種があって芽が出ると
葉っぱ 葉っぱ 幹などが現れて成長する
それから花があると 次に実ると
その実の中にまた種があるとかね
そうすると時間の経過があるんですね
それはタイムラインというんですね
神がいる アダムとイブを創造する
もう天界から追放される
それから徐々に世界で人間が現れていくという宗教の話を
このタイムラインで語っているんです
これは間違いということはよくわかるでしょう
卵が先か鶏が先かという質問は
時間のラインでできたものです
じゃあ答えがないですよ
卵が先 鶏が先 タイムラインで答えが出てこない
だからその同じ論理で神を創ったんです
アダムとイブと創ったんです
だからもう笑い話以外何でもないんです
答えがないだけではなく
本当の因果論でもないんですね
だからこれ タイムラインというのは
ちょっと簡単にタイムラインだと思っちゃうんです
仏教の縁の特色 縁起そのものについて観察する
だから縁起という そこに強調するんですね
現象よりも縁起というところに強調するんです
いわゆるプリンシパルというか
方式に 方式大事にすると
現象ってそれほど問題になってこないんです
何かの現象が現れた 現れるために
原因だけではなく条件も必要ですね
これパーリ語でヘイトとパッチと呼ぶんです
だから なぜで原因だけ見つけたら困ると
原因があっても結果出ない場合があるんです
条件もあるんですね 科学化学の場合は
これこれ合わせればこんな結果になるんだということで
因果法則を決めますよ
しかし 触媒とか何とかして
化学反応を早くさせる
あるいは遅くする 何か入れちゃいますね
あれは化学反応に参加しないんです
やっぱりあの環境の中で早くなったり遅くなったりする
それが縁ですね パッチですね
縁起はタイムラインとこのシマイトエニス
あるいはシンコニックというね
2つの次元で起こっているんです
もうタイムラインだけではなくて
同時に起こるという いわゆる原因と結果の間で時間の差がない場合もあります
この両方考えなくちゃいけない
例勉強したから合格できました
これタイムラインですね
勉強は先にする 後で合格する
例照明があるから本を読める
本が読めるということは結果
照明あるということは原因
時間ずれたら困るでしょ
一緒にないと 一つの現象に複数の原因と条件が必要です
それらのすべてを発見しないと
縁起を発見したことにはならないのです
したがって 縁起は難しいんです
はい それから今日必要なこの実用的縁起なんですね
仏教の修行以外にも縁起を使用できます
ブッダが縁起法則を喋ったのは
我々に瞑想して悟るためなんです
しかし 日常生活でも縁起は適用できます
だから科学は使ってますから
科学者に何かあれこれと言う必要はない
我々 日常生きてる場合もね
だから何が起きたっても原因があるんだぞとかね
と覚えちゃえばいいでしょうに
だから調べないで気に付けないことでしょ
わからないことはわからないんだと
今日は旦那が調子が悪いんだけどね
気分が悪いんだけど 何かあったでしょうと
なんであんたその調子取ってるのかではなくて
何かあったの？とかね
それでなんで気分が悪くなってるの？何かあったの？と聞けばいい
黙れと言ったら あ 言いたくはないと
それで自分にそこ その瞬間の縁起でしょ
この瞬間の縁起で問題解決するんです
旦那が気分が斜めで 奥さんが縁起法則で何か原因があるでしょうにと
原因わかったら何か助けてあげることもできますから
親切に ちょっとあんたね
もうなんか気分がおかしいんだ
何かあったの？と うるさい
黙っておこうと 喧嘩を売ってはあかん
その時は それで因果法則で考えてください
言いたくない それだけでしょう
それで本人が 奥さんがピーッと黙ってまた台所に行ったら
もしかして旦那さんがなんだこの女とまた怒るかもしれません
それでなんであなたのその調子はと
だからあなたは言いたくないんだから
うせ帰りましたと それだけでしょうね
結果は言えば言いたくない
私は聞きたく聞かないで言った
それって違うでしょと言ったら
だったら言ってください
原因はと 聞いてあげましょうと
それで問題解決でしょうに
だから常にこの因果法則で調べれば
あまりこのタイムラインでいってはいけません
例えば 本を読んで勉強している
なんか気持ち悪くなっちゃって
やりたくなくなっちゃう
なんで今勉強したくなくなったのかと
その瞬間で見れば その瞬間の原因見えるんです
そこを調整すれば OK
だからいつでもこのシマルテーネスということに挑戦してみてください
タイムラインは放っておいてください
皆様 この日本の社会でも宗教
社会 精神 社会でね このタイムラインに皆様引っかかってもらって騙されているんです
あなたはなかなか あなたは芸能人なのになかなか売れないのは
あなたは全然ひいひいひいひいおじいさんのお墓参りしていないんだからと
だから 猿を供養すれば幸福になるならば
今日から皆様猿を供養してください
だって猿は猿ですからね
だからタイムライン あるいはアメーバを拝んだらどうですかね
だって戦争はアメーバでしょ
タイムラインで言っちゃうと馬鹿を見るんです
でも我々は縁起と言った途端
原因結果と言った途端
タイムラインと思っちゃうでしょ
だから実証編ではもうタイムラインを忘れてください
それはないわけじゃないんです
ありますが  2つ側面があります
私たちに管理できるのは
今のところシマウマテーネスセクションだけなんです
過去起きたことは過去起きたんだから
もうもう変えられません
だからタイムラインの因果法則はもう勉強にはいいんだけど
変更することはできないんです
それだけ覚えておけば
皆様すごい知識人になるんです
だから決して過去に起きた原因を探さないこと
わかって悪くないんです
でも今の問題の答えじゃないんで
まあそんな何が まあそんなところですからね
あんまりまあもうのとばします
で 我々に原因を調べることできないのはもう感情で
無知で だからもうこれできないんですね
また勝手な演技をつけようってみるんですね
こういうところは危険で
やってはいけないことで
だから注意点がない 時間ですね
時間の感覚が長くなると
正しい原因は見えなくなるんです
このタイムラインの場合は
時間が伸ばせば伸ばすほどわからなくなるんですね
例えば  sex したっても
まあ両親のことを知っている
おじいさん おばあさんのことも知っている
それから知っている  名前ぐらい知っているとか
もっと先に行っちゃうと
誰の誰かわからなくなるでしょうに
だからそんなのはもう探す必要ないんですよ
簡単で アニマを拝んでください
もう面倒くさい 小学生の頃
問題が起きたと推測して調べても
原因は見いだせませんよ
時間感覚は 30年もあります
30歳の人がね  35歳の人が自分には自信がないというね
問題が起きます なんで自信がないのは
小学校の時は何があったんでしょうかと
いい加減にしろよと私が言いたいんですよ
もう見つかりっこはね
もう忘れているんです
わかってどうするんですかね
小学校ですごくひどくバカにされたと
みんなの前でむちゃくちゃ言われたんだと
舞台の上ですごい恥かきましたと
ブタで何か泳ぎ会なんとかやったところで
服が落ちてきて裸になってしまったとかね
それでそので だから 35歳の私は自信がないんだと
いい加減にしてもう忘れているでしょ
そんなことは 今更わかってどうする？例えば
その先生の言葉が悪かったと
先生は小学校の時はもう 35歳だとしましょう
この人は今 35歳で 自分の自信がないことに解決策を探しちゃうんですね
やっぱり先生の言葉が悪かった
あいつは今でもあいつにあいつに謝らさなくちゃいけないんだと
今 先生は何歳？まあ  65歳でもう退職してるんですね
どこかの田舎で そのどこかで田舎で畑作ってるおじいさんを探して探って
あのね あなたは謝りなさい
君なんだいと で 思い出されて
あ そう あ これ悪かったと思わないんで
なんだあんたはと その時でも
じゃから出て これはそう言いませんでしたと謝ったっても
自信がどーんと出ていく
これが我々がやっている大きな心理学の世界でもね
大きな問題なんです これ
人の記憶が悪いだけではなくて
時間感覚が長くなると
その原因も消えているんですよ
瞬間で消えるんです それだからなんです
だから今関係ないなんです
今起きる現象の今にある原因と縁を探せば
明確に発見することができます
今座って本を読んでいると
気分が悪くなったら 今その答えを見つからなくちゃいけないんです
その程度で時間ちょっと経過しましたので
因果法則は人間に幸福を与えるんですよ
苦しくなった途端 解決できます
物事うまくいかないなとわかったら
すぐその場の原因だけ探ってください
例で言えば アメリカでいろいろ問題が起きて
経済不振に日本まで引きずりてしまったという話があるんですね
だからこの今 今 今ということやっちゃう
その問題は起きないんですね
例えば あのもうリーマン・ブラザーズは倒産するしたって聞いた瞬間で
こちらが今の瞬間にどうするべきかと
パンパンパンパンと自分の財産をなくならないように何とかするだけで
それ今だけの対策や だから文句を言うなよと
明日変えますよという調子で
これ待っていれば良くなりますよっていうのは答えじゃないんです
あれはもう神を信仰してるんだからなんです
先知先覚の だから極限な愚かもんなんです
爆弾が弾けた時でも 時間経てば治ると言ってはあかん
その答えは とんでもないバカな話なんです
例えば もう旦那さんが死んじゃったら
奥さんが落ち込んじゃう
まあ時間経てばそれ あるいは振られたと
それ傷つくのですね  時間は直してくれる
タイムヒールという言葉もあるでしょ
そうなんですが それ良くないんです
時間はもう 2年経って治すならば
2 年間この傷跡 引き続けなくちゃいかんでしょうね
傷っていうのは放っておけば大きくなっちゃうんです
海までで溜まっちゃうんです
だからすぐ今それを直さなくちゃいけないんです
瞬時に もうはい  OK 終わった
振られた ああ まあいいや
さようなら そういう風にきちっと入れ替える能力は因果法則を与えてくれるんです
持ち運べないんです 過去は
そこがものすごい幸福の話ですよ
また この幸福は科学的で現実的で
微塵も神秘はないんです
で 仏教はそういう幸福を語っている因果法則なんです
だから難しいんですから
もう今日用意したものもまだ半分ありますけども
もうどうしようもないんです
で だからこの最後のスライドぐらいでも出します
だから可能性に富んでいる
インスピレーションとかいろいろタイトルを入れましたけどね
因果法則で生きてると
いつでもインスピレーションが出てくるんです
新しいアイディア 新しいアイディア
いくらでも出ます あ それで終わり
どうもありがとうございます
いつもは講演の時に 最後に皆さんで功徳を回向して終わりにしておりますので
今日もそのようにして終わりたいと思います
それでは 皆さんもこちらに出ている回向の文を唱えて終わりたいと思います
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩が減らされますように
サッバーディティーオーイバンジャントゥ
サンバローボーイナッサトーマテーバワットアンテラーヨ
スキーディーガーイコーバーガー
ババトゥサンバマンガラングラックカントゥ
サンバデーヴァタサンバブンダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマーヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ
サダーソッティーバワントゥテー
サーリプッタサーリプッタサーリプッタ
はい ありがとうございます
本当に質問の時間がなくなって申し訳ございません
これからできるだけ省略してしゃべろうと思います
[applause]